my name is Hank Greely it's actually
formally Henry Teague really that's high
published but i go by hank and the Dean
f & Kate Edelman Johnson professor of
law and a professor by courtesy of
genetics at Stanford University where I
direct the Stanford center for law in
the bio sciences and the Stanford
program in neuroscience and society the
first time I saw Stanford was March of
68 I was a sophomore in high school and
my high school debate team from Southern
California came here for a tournament
and I fell in love with the place I came
back for four years as an undergrad from
1972 1974 where I got my bachelor's
degree in science but it was political
science went off to Yale Law School
clerked for a couple of federal judges
worked in the Carter Administration got
back to California but Southern
California to work in a law firm as a
litigator in 1985 i joined the Stanford
Law School faculty and I've been here
ever since have been married a doctor
when I started teaching law school I
started teaching health law in 1990-91
the university put on a series of big
three-day Centennial symposia to
celebrate the hundredth anniversary of
the founding of the University one of
them was other than new human genome
project and the organizers Paul Berg
David Botstein Lucy Shapiro wanted a law
professor on the Planning Committee and
since then 1991 or so most of my work
has been a bad legal ethical of social
issues in genetics I branched out Sam I
do neuroscience stem cell research is
this into reproduction but over that
time genetics has certainly been more
than half of my work
you